elon reeve musk was born to a canadian
mother and south african father on june
28 1971 in pretoria south africa
his mother mae musk is an international
best-selling author dietitian model and
speaker
now in her 70s she is the oldest cover
girl and a supermodel
his father aeromusk was an
electromechanical engineer and the
youngest person to get a professional
engineer's qualification in south africa
he was also a sailor and a pilot
his younger brother kimball musk was
born in 1972 is a restaurateur who owns
the kitchen restaurant group and is the
co-founder and chairman of big green
their younger sister tosca musk born in
1974 is an executive producer filmmaker
whose work includes kay bromberg's
driven she's also the co-founder of
passionflix
elon also has two half-sisters from his
father's side alexandra musk and asha
rose musk
his first wife was justine musk a
canadian author they were married from
2000 to 2008 and have six sons together
tallulah riley a british actress was his
second wife their relationship was
complicated as they tied the knot twice
first in 2010
and then in two years they split up only
to renew their vows again in 2013. they
split up the final time in 2016.
he's currently dating grimes a canadian
singer and they have one son together
after his parents divorced in 1980 elon
lived mostly with his father in the
suburbs of pretoria he attended the
private waterloof house preparatory
school and later graduated from pretoria
boys high school musk was severely
bullied as a child and was once
hospitalized when a group of boys threw
him down a flight of stairs and then
beat him until he lost consciousness he
started to learn how to fight back and
took up karate judo and wrestling
he was an avid reader and at only 10
started teaching himself programming on
the commodore vic 20.
at age 12 he sold the code of a basic
game called blast star to a magazine
called pc and office technology for 500
a web version of the game is still
available online today
at 17 he moved to canada and obtained a
canadian passport through his canadian
mother musk left south africa to avoid
serving in the south african military
whose main duty at the time was
enforcing apartheid
he enrolled in queens university in
kingston ontario it was there that he
met his first wife justine wilson
after two years at queens he transferred
to the university of pennsylvania where
he received a bachelor of science degree
in physics and a bachelor of science
degree in economics
in 1994 musk did his internship in
silicon valley at an energy storage
startup called pinnacle research
institute
in 1995 at the age of 24 he moved to
california to pursue a phd in applied
physics at stanford university but left
the program after just two days to
pursue entrepreneurship focusing on the
internet renewable energy and outer
space
[Music]
in 1995 musk kimball and greg curry
founded zip 2 with 28 000 in funds from
angel investors it was a web software
company that would help newspapers
develop online city guides zip2 was
acquired by compact's alta vista web
search engine for a whopping
340 million dollars in 1999.
from the sale of zip2 he created x.com
an online financial services and email
payment company that attracted over 200
000 customers within the initial months
being the first online bank to be
federally insured
the company's investors had musk
replaced with intuit ceo bill harris
citing musk's inexperience
x.com merged with the online bank
confinity the following year confinity
had its own money transfer service
called paypal which was more popular
than x.com service the company was
renamed paypal in 2001.
in 2002 paypal was acquired by ebay for
1.5 billion dollars in stock of which
elon musk was the largest shareholder
who received over 100 million dollars
musk purchased the domain name x.com
from paypal in 2017 for an undisclosed
amount explaining it had sentimental
value to him
in 2001 musk became involved with the
non-profit mars society in october musk
went to moscow to buy refurbished
intercontinental ballistic missiles
icbms he was seen as a novice and spat
on by one of the russian chief designers
in february 2002 they returned to russia
looking for three icbms and were offered
one rocket for eight million dollars
which must rejected and decided to start
a company that would build affordable
rockets himself
in 2002 he founded space exploration
technologies or spacex which failed
three times on its launch only to
succeed in launching the falcon 1 in
2008 it was the first private liquid
fuel rocket launch to reach earth's
orbit
in that year spacex received a 1.6
billion dollar commercial resupply
services program contract for 12 flights
of its falcon 9 rocket and dragon
spacecraft to the international space
station replacing the space shuttle
must work towards reducing the expense
of spaceflight by developing a fully
reusable rocket that could lift off and
return to the pad it launched from
beginning in 2012 spacex's grasshopper
rocket made several short flights to
test the technology
musk was also chief designer in building
the falcon rockets dragon and
grasshopper in 2015 spacex successfully
landed the first stage of a falcon 9.
in 2017 spacex unveiled its next
generation launch vehicle and spacecraft
system big falcon rocket in 2018 spacex
announced a planned 2023 lunar
circumnavigation mission a private
flight called the deer moon project
in 2020 spacex launched its first main
flight the demo 2 becoming the first
private company to place a person in the
orbit and dock a crew spacecraft with
the international space station
within spacex is the starlink mission
beginning in 2015 two prototype test
flight satellites were later launched in
february 2018 for the starlink mission
which is a satellite internet
constellation being constructed by
spacex providing satellite internet
access the constellation will consist of
thousands of mass-produced small
satellites in low earth orbit working in
combination with ground transceivers
musk started funding tesla motors in
2004 leading the series a round of
investments and joining tesla's board of
directors as chairman
when the ceo was ousted from the firm
musk assumed leadership of the company
in 2008 as ceo and chief product
architect
tesla first built an electric sports car
the roadster in 2008 and sold about 2
500 vehicles it was the first serial
production all-electric car to use
lithium-ion battery cells
in 2012 tesla introduced the model s
sedan the model x luxury suv went on the
market in 2015. the model 3 a less
expensive vehicle went into production
in 2017 and as of march 2020 it is the
world's best-selling electric car with
deliveries over 500 000 units
in 2019 the cyber truck an all-electric
pickup truck was unveiled and the model
y crossover was launched in 2020.
tesla has also constructed multiple
lithium-ion battery and electric vehicle
sub-assembly factories such as the
gigafactory one in nevada and the
gigafactory 3 in china
in 2020 tesla became the most valuable
car maker in the world and it entered
the s p 500 later on that year
in 2014 musk committed to building a
solar city advanced production facility
in buffalo new york triple the size of
the largest solar plant in the united
states it was completed in 2017 and was
a joint venture with panasonic who left
in 2020
tesla acquired solar city for over 2
billion in 2016 and converted it into
its solar division
in 2016 musk started a neurotechnology
company neurolink whose aim was to
integrate the human brain with
artificial intelligence the purpose is
to create devices that are embedded in
the human brain to facilitate the
merging of the brain with machines and
also reconcile with the latest
improvements in ai to stay updated
in 2014 musk pulled his children out of
their private school to start the future
of changing education the first step was
to unschool them and then create his own
little school according to the needs for
the future
it was the experimental school that
started in one of spacex's factories to
give an education to his own children
and selected children of spacex
employees more in tune with the reality
these children will have to face in the
future
the astra nova school was co-founded
designed and run by the former ad astra
school team students learn about
simulations case studies fabrications
and design projects labs and corporate
collaborations
has been teasing the idea of a hyperloop
with an estimated speed of
675 miles per hour which is about three
times faster than high speed rail and 10
to 15 times faster than traditional rail
2008 in particular was was was awful
because
we had the third launch failure in a row
of
of our falcon 1 vehicle at
spacex and um
we uh
the tesla financing round that we were
raising fell apart
um because the economy was going to
tailspin
um and it's pretty hard to raise money
for a startup car company uh you know
late 2008 when jim and chrysler are busy
going bankrupt
um
that that was that was tough and then
solar city had a deal with morgan
stanley and morgan stanley had to renege
on the deal because they themselves
running out of money
so it looked like all three companies
were going to die
and i was also going through divorce so
that was definitely a low point
so it's 2008 you're going through a
divorce which like some
to borrow your word douchebag bloggers
are writing about to make even worse
right yes that's true um in addition to
all that stuff happening i was getting
dumped on massively in the press right
yeah you're you know it looks like all
three companies yeah are gonna file i
mean
why do you keep going with all three
like i feel like even a lot of great
entrepreneurs in that situation would
have been like i've already sunk
everything i have in these companies
and i gotta pick one
but you didn't i mean you kept doing all
three why um yeah that was that was a
very tough call
um
at the end of 2008 that was that was
probably the top you know one of the
toughest goals i've had to make
because i could either
um
reserve capital for one company or the
other i mean before solo city didn't
need a ton of capital so they were okay
um but between spacex and and and tesla
um
you know it's sort of like like you've
got two kids and
what do you do do you spend all your
money to to maximize probably the
success of one or do you
you try to keep both light unfortunately
it worked it's very important to to seek
out to actively seek out
and listen very carefully to negative
feedback
um
and this is something that people tend
to avoid because it's it's painful yeah
um
but
but i think this is a very common
mistake is to to not actively seek out
and listen to
uh negative feedback what do you do that
you go into forums do you go into
twitter like what are your areas where
you go to look for feedback on let's say
the tesla
well it's like everyone i talk to is in
fact when um when friends get a product
i say look i don't tell me what you like
tell me what you don't like right
um and and because otherwise your friend
is not going to tell you what he doesn't
like right this kid's going to say oh i
love this and that and and then and
leave out the this is the stuff i don't
like list because too much of your
friend one you know it doesn't want to
offend you so um
so you really need to
to to to to sort of coax negative
feedback um and you should you know that
if somebody is your friend or at least
not your enemy and they're giving you
negative feedback um
then
they may be wrong but it's coming from a
good place
and sometimes even your enemies give you
good negative feedback you know and
generally
you want to embark on something it's
desirable to figure out if success is at
least one of the possibilities right
exactly
because for sure failure is one of the
possibilities yes um but but ideally you
want to try to
bracket it and say
success is in the envelope of outcomes
yeah
and i wasn't quite sure if that was the
case
i mean i think success on an academic
level would have been quite likely
because you can publish some useless
paper and uh
most papers are pretty useless um you
know we have a few don't take effect
i mean
how many php papers are actually used by
someone ever
i mean it's a good point percentage-wise
it's not it's not good
and
so
so it could have been one of those
outcomes where
you add some
leaves to the tree of knowledge yeah
okay um and then that leaf is nope it's
not possible
like right
they go seven years a month
[Laughter]
so that
so that was one path and i was prepared
to do that but then the internet was
eric came along and i was like okay the
internet i'm pretty sure success is one
of the possible outcomes and it seemed
like i could either do
do sort of do a phd and watch the
internet happen or i could participate
and help build in some fashion you know
you know
like i just couldn't stand the idea of
watching it happen yeah yeah so that
that's uh so i decided to put things on
hold uh and start an internet company
the secret to your success to be the ceo
of two companies at the same time no
i think it's uh because look at the
correlation yeah struggling companies
everything's in the craft can in
december 2008. so let's take on a new
ceo gig yeah and same for steve coming
back to alpha no it definitely was not
my intention to be co2 companies um
the uh
i mean after i mean
i i there are certain things that i kind
of wanted to i thought were important to
happen and i thought it was important
that
um that there was
that that electric vehicle happened that
there was a success in the electric
vehicle arena uh because the
the incumbent companies were convinced
that it was not possible to create a an
electric car that looked good had rain a
good range performance and so forth
and that even if you did make such a car
it would not sell
at because people had this love of
gasoline
and
so we had to show that
it was possible to create
a compelling electric car long range
good looking you know all those things
that was a tesla roadster and if you
created if if you made such a thing
people would buy it some
longer term family ownership at least at
least a portion of it so it's it acts as
a positive influence
this is still something i'm thinking
about but acting as a positive influence
in in the long terms that the company
kind of does
those proper long-term things um
like i'm
you know look at what happened also in
in silicon valley with with hp and i
think it's quite quite quite sad
and um
and that that to some degree is because
there was
um
much diminished uh
influenced by
the the
hewlett and packard families right um
i think they should have prevailed in in
in their you know in were they opposed
to
the merger that took place at one point
and i think they were right actually
right and keeping i'm looking to the
future for spacex is there an ipo plan
for this year no there's no ipo plan no
um
let's say running a public company
is
does have its drawbacks um so you're not
in a hurry
no
okay um i mean in the case of
tesla and spacex
we had to raise capital um and and we
had kind of a complex equity structure
that needed to be resolved by by going
public
um
and um
and so so i thought we kind of needed to
do that in those two cases
we don't have to do that in spacex i
think
there's a good chance it will at some
point in the future
but but spacex's objectives are super
long term and and the market is
is not
so i'm a bit worried that if we did go
public certainly if we're in public too
soon that it that that market pressure
would would force us to do
uh
short-term things and abandon kind of
long-term projects like going to mars
right green wire very long term you want
to have like a
good competitive forcing function so
that uh you have to make the product
better uh or or you'll lose like if you
don't make the product better and and
improve the product for the end consumer
then then that company should have
relatively less prosperity compared to
company that makes better products um
now the car industry you know it is
actually pretty competitive
so that's good
um
and
but and then the the the good thing
about a competitive company in industry
is that if you make a product that's
better it's gonna do better in the
marketplace i think failure is bad um i
don't think it's good um but
if if if something's important enough
then you you do it even though the risk
of failure is high
and and so i think my advice if somebody
wants to start a company is they should
bear in mind that the most likely
outcome is is that it's not going to
work
and they should reconcile themselves to
that
past strong possibility
and they should only do it if they feel
that they're
they're they're really compelled to do
it
you know right
[Music]
because it's
it's gonna the way starting company
works is like usually in the beginning
it's the very beginning it's kind of fun
um
and then it's really hellish for for
a number of years you talked about
chewing glass
yeah there's
there's a friend of mine who's a
successful entrepreneur
um and uh
started actually his career around the
same time as i did and he has a good
good good phrase his name's bully uh
he said yeah you're starting companies
like eating glass and staring into the
abyss
and
and you agree with that
generally true
um yeah
and and and if you don't eat the glass
you're not going to be successful well
we have a lot of good good people at
spacex that
um
a lot of really talented people
uh
in fact i wonder like sometimes
how we can make use of their talents
in the best way because you know i think
we're often not using their talents in
the best way
yeah but
you know to the point of the question i
was just asked i want to make sure tesla
recruiting does not have anything that
says requires
university because that's absurd
uh
but there is a requirement of evidence
of exceptional ability
like you just can't if you're trying to
do something exceptional they must have
evidence of exceptional ability i don't
consider going to college evidence of
exceptional ability
in fact
ideally you dropped out and did
something
i mean obviously you know look at like
you know
gates is a pretty smart guy he dropped
out
uh john was pretty smart he dropped out
you know larry allison smart guy he
dropped out
like
obviously not needed well i think of the
these things is just
there's a certain amount of time and
within that time you want the
the best net outcome so
for
you know all the set of actions that you
can do
there's going to be
and some of which will fail some of
which will succeed
and you want th the
the net useful
output of your set of actions to be the
highest
um
so
um
i'm going to like use like a baseball
analogy like
you know baseball they don't let you
just sit there and wait for the perfect
pitch until that you get a real easy one
they didn't give you three shots and
then the third one
they say okay they
get off the
go back to the
put somebody else up there um
so these three strikes on on the
baseball
um
not you know not only bad anymore so
so what you're what you're really
looking for is like what's the batting
average
you know how you doing on
on score
and just
there's going to be some amount of
failure
but you want your net output
that useful output to be maximized
failure is essentially irrelevant
unless it is catastrophic so you want to
have a
competitive
situation where it's truly competitive
uh where companies aren't gaming the
system um and
and then where the rules are set
correctly um and then you need to be on
the alert for regulatory capture where
the
the referees are in fact captured by the
players
which is you know and
the players should not control the
referees so you're running you're ceo of
two companies you're chairman of solar
city
talk about time management how on earth
do you do this
well do you get any sleep
uh
yeah sometimes not enough sleep is
really great uh because
because if i find if i don't get enough
sleep then i'm i'm quite grumpy
um
i mean obviously i think most people
that way
and and and also
um like i try to sort of figure out
what's the right amount of sleep
because like i found i could have
i could drop below a certain threshold
of sleep and although i'd be awake more
hours and i could sustain it i would get
less done because
my
mental acuity would be affected
so i found generally the right number
for me is around six to six and a half
hours on average per night
that's not too bad yeah right and any
other tips on average though
any other tips on just managing to run
two companies simultaneously i mean do
you do you find i mean i know you're up
here monday tuesday is it all tesla when
you're up in silicon valley and all
spacex wednesday thursday it's
having a
sort of as
having a smartphone is incredibly
helpful because that means you can do
email during um interstitial periods
like you're in a car you're walking in
the bathroom everywhere you can do email
practically when you're awake
um
and uh
and so that's really helpful to have
email for spacex and tesla integrated
on my phone um and then uh
and then it's just you have to apply a
lot of hours to actual working actually
working so
the way i generally do it is i'll be
uh
working at spacex on monday and then
monday night flight to the bay area
spent tuesday
in wednesday at the barrier
then at tesla and then flight back on
wednesday night spent thursday and
friday at spacex
in
the last several months then i would fly
back here on a saturday
and either spend saturday and sunday at
tesla
or
spend saturday at tesla and sunday at
spacex well we've got a lot of work to
do
because we've got
a lot of service centers
and charge stations to construct
so mostly it's like we're trying to
build our service and charge
infrastructure as fast as possible
and
i know this like some of the customers
who have ordered a car they're not in
the major cities so
they're a little unhappy with us because
we are delaying delivery of their car
and
in fact i'm going to apologize to some
of them personally
to exp and explain the reason we are
delaying deliveries because it's we
really want them to have a good
experience but if they're too far from a
service center and and the charging is
not sorted out then they will not have a
good experience um so
we're
going to delay their cars just for a few
months to make sure that they have a
good experience i think it's also
important to reason from first
principles rather than by analogy so the
normal way that we conduct our lives is
we we
we reason by analogy
it's we're doing this because
it's like something else that was done
or it's like what um other people are
doing me too type ideas yeah it's like
yeah iterations yeah on on a theme um
and and uh
and it's
it because it's it's kind of mentally
easier to reason by analogy rather than
from first principles but by first
principles is kind of a physics way of
looking at the world and what that
really means is
you kind of boil things down to the most
fundamental truths
and and say okay what are we sure is
true or as sure as possible is true
and then reason up from there
that takes a lot more mental energy um
give me an example that like what's one
thing that you've you've done that on
that you feels worked for you sure so
um somebody could say um in fact people
do uh that battery packs are really
expensive and that's just the way
they'll always be because that's the way
they've been in the past some of us
noticed that the stereo goes to 11 right
on the tesla this is a spinal type
reference for those who know that this
this one goes to 11 and you just just
won more it's louder than loud that's
right exactly that's right
but no one seems to have noticed the
product lineup so you got the model s
you got the model x oh yeah you've just
trademarked the model e
i know exactly well there's no i guess
there's not a lot of humor and trademark
uh the trademark law you know
um
because yeah obviously we just
trademarked sexy um
so
uh and and then we're having this this
discussion with the
like ford um because they um
for the ford's council uh
uh
they also didn't get it like because
they're they're
sort of slightly opposing us using model
e
um and then they saw that we registered
model y and they say oh you're planning
to use model y instead of model e like
no it's just a joke when trying
different things
you've got to have some acceptance of
failure as you're alluding to earlier
failure must be an option if failure is
not an option it's going to result in
extremely conservative choices and
you you may not may get something even
worse than lack of innovation things may
go backwards
um
so um if
what you really want is
uh
risk risk
to you you want reward and punishment to
to be proportionate to the actions that
you seek
so if
uh if what you're seeking is innovation
then you should reward success and
innovation
um and
only
there should be
minor consequences for lack of
minor consequences for trying and
failing
should they should be minor
um with significant rewards for trying
and succeeding
minor consequences for trying and not
succeeding
and big
and
major negative consequences for not
trying or maybe i just blank out the
word doubt
okay
um
so uh no i mean i totally frank i
doubted us too so i thought we you know
had maybe
when starting spacex maybe had a 10
chance of reaching orbit so
so you know to those who who doubted us
i was like well i think you're probably
right you know um i mean there were
times uh
that i was told like
uh because i everyone's taking the money
that earned from from paypal and
enrolling into
to create spacex and tesla and and
that's enough spending it all it wasn't
the intention but
um
and and and uh almost both companies
went bankrupt frankly 2008 was a tough
year
um
you know it took us took us four
attempts just to get to orbit with
falcon one
um
and uh
so but a lot of times i was you know i
people would tell me this joke like how
do you make a small fortune in the
rocket industry you start with a large
one is the punch line
and i was like okay i already heard that
joke 12 000 times you know
so
so
anyway um and it was it almost came true
um
you know we just barely made it there
that fourth launch of falcon one that's
all the money we had for that fourth
launch
and then uh and that wasn't even enough
to to save the company we also then had
to win the nasa cargo resupply contract
um so that that came a little after you
know a little bit later or towards the
end of 2008 um those are the two key
things that that saved spacex otherwise
we would have we would have you know
not made it so
um
so yeah i think those those doubters
were
their probability assessment was correct
um but fortunately uh
vader smiled upon us and brought us to
this day but one of the fun things for
me is watching the the the cargo go into
the crew vessel you know all of a sudden
we had dragon one now we have crew
dragon and it's substantially different
but familiar so tell us like what's been
some of the hardest parts to transition
from cargo
into crew because the crew is a little
more important than
than cargo yes i mean cargo can be
replaced crew cannot um and so the
the level of scrutiny the level of
attention is
i mean i don't know order of magnitude
greater it was it was already high for
cargo i mean
and and uh but it's it's just a whole
other level for for a crew
so
you have and after i told the spacex
team that you know the
uh
this mission reliability is not really
the top priority it is the only priority
right now um so we're just doing
continuous uh engineering reviews uh
from now non-stop uh 24 hours a day
until launch just gone over everything
again and again and again and i was out
at the pad just recently just walking
down the rocket
um we've got a team that's just crawling
over the rocket in the horizontal then
we're going to rotate it vertical then
we're going to crawl all over in the
vertical
and
we're just looking for
any
any possible action that can improve the
probability of success no matter how
small whether that comes from an intern
or me or anyone it doesn't matter when i
started the first uh interact companies
up to um
with my brother and another person um a
great curry the
uh it wasn't really with the thought of
being wealthy
you know got anything against being
wealthy but
um
we'll get back to that later
but it's just it was just from the
standpoint i've been wanting to be part
of the internet and uh
i i figured if we could make enough
money to just get by i would be that'll
be okay
um and when we when we started off uh we
we
literally only had like one computer and
so it would be our web server during the
day and i'd code at night
um and we we just got a
a small office um
in palo alto back when rent was not
insane um
and
uh it cost us like 450 dollars a month
it was cheaper than an apartment so we
actually just slept in the office and
then
and then showered at the ymca at page
mill el camino so we'd walk over there
and and shower and uh
and that was um
actually i think uh
that was when i we first i first met you
by the way um and uh
so i don't know how many people probably
know many people know this but uh
we actually pitched uh steve in like
january 96
on uh the zip2 business plan uh and
actually i thought
she was
actually one of the most up to speed on
on what actually was in our business
plan most most people we met did not
actually read our business plan
um in fact a lot of people a lot of
venture capitalists we met at the time
didn't even know what the internet was
or
they've never used they've never used
them
yeah like you know sort of well-known
people on sand hill i was like wow okay
um
but at the time nobody made any any
money on the internet so i guess that's
um
you know it then it wasn't really clear
evidence that there was was a business i
mean i should say that you know when i
was a kid i didn't really have any grand
designs i mean the the reason i started
programming computers is because i like
computer games um and i play lots of
computer games and
i learned that if i wrote software and
sold it then i could get more money and
buy better computers so it wasn't really
you know with some grand vision or
anything
when i was growing up i'd read lots of
books and
they were very often set in the united
states and it seemed like a lot of new
technology was being developed in the
united states so i i thought okay i
really want to work on new technology so
i want to get to silicon valley
um you know which when i was growing up
silicon valley seemed like some sort of
mythical place
uh you know like mount olympus or
something i think one thing that's
important is
uh if you have a choice of a lower
valuation uh with someone you really
like or a higher evaluation with someone
you have a question mark about take the
lower evaluation
it's better to have
a higher quality
venture capitalist who you think is it
would be great to work with than to
you know get a higher evaluation with
someone
where there's
even a question mark really you know i
think that's that's important it's sort
of like getting married you know what
sort of things do you look for in people
or in processes that make the workforce
better
sure well i think
the massive thing that can be done is to
make sure your incentive structure is
such that
innovation is rewarded and lack of
innovation is punished they've got to be
a characteristic
so
if somebody is
innovating
and
doing making good progress
then they should be promoted sooner
and if somebody is completely failing to
innovate
not every role requires innovation but
if they're in a role where innovation is
should be happening and it's not
happening then they should
either not be promoted or exited
and let me tell you you'll get promoted
you'll get you'll you'll get innovation
real fast your actual total mass of a
steel
uh
of a reusable steel spacecraft is less
than that of the most advanced carbon
fiber
vehicle
you could possibly imagine yeah wow but
this
happened by accident by the way this may
sound like some great insight but it
actually happened because we were moving
too slowly on composite
and i was like we cannot move this
slowly or we'll go bankrupt so
just do this with steel so yeah i mean
the design has to be focused on problem
solving otherwise you're going to spend
too much time trying to figure you don't
start with a
yeah yeah i'm like
sort of taken to management management
by rhyming if the schedule is
schedule is long your design is wrong
right
this is very true
so zip2 started off
as
basically
uh like so we're trying to figure out
how to how to make enough money to exist
as a company and
the
so since there wasn't really any
advertising money being made
we thought we could um
help existing companies
get online bring their stuff online so
we developed software that helped bring
um
love in newspapers and media companies
online because they alone just didn't
they also didn't know what the internet
was big customers didn't yeah
um and even the ones that were aware of
the internet didn't have a software team
so they could they weren't very good at
developing functionality
um and so we had as
investors and customers uh the new york
times company knight redder hearst
and and so we were able to
get them to pay us to develop software
for them to bring them online so online
publishing stuff we did maps and
directions and yellow pages and white
pages and
various other things i did briefly in
college um
who now works at scientific american as
a writer and uh and and she related the
anecdote that uh we were on a date i was
what i was talking about was electric
that was not a winning conversation
so was a bit of a monologue was it yeah
she said uh she said the first question
i asked her was do you ever think about
electric cars
no she
you don't need college learning learn
stuff okay
everything is available basically for
free
you can learn anything you want for free
it is not a question of learning
um
there there is
a value that colleges have which is like
you know seeing whether somebody's
is can somebody work hard at something
including a bunch of
sort of annoying homework assignments
and still do their homework assignments
uh and and kind of soldier through and
and get it done
you know that's
that's like
the main value of college and then also
you know if you you
probably want to hang around with a
bunch of people your own age for a while
instead of going right into the
workforce
so i think colleges are basically for
fun and to prove you can do your chores
but they're not for learning when i was
in in high school i thought i'd most
likely be doing physics out of particle
accelerator
so that's what as
um
physics and computers i mean i got
distinctions in two areas in physics and
computer science and those were
yeah so my two best subjects and
i
and then i thought okay well that i want
to figure out what's the nature of the
universe and um
so
you know go try to
working with people banging particles
together to see what happens
um
and um
and then it sort of things went along
and the the super conducting super
collider got cancelled in the us and
that actually was like whoa you know
what if i i'm working at a collider
i spent all these years and then the
government just canceled it wow and then
that would was like hopefully i can do
that
so
um
so it's like
so
well we roll back a little
um
like i tried to figure out what when i
was killing i had like this existential
crisis and i was about 12 years old or
something and
and i was like well what does the world
mean wait
what's it all about are we living some
meaningless existence
and and then um
i met i made the mistake of reading
nietzsche and chopin now and
yes and i'm like
wow
don't do that they're not it's not it's
not
a little older i think no no actually
lately these days i still rear it so
like
you know it's actually he's not that bad
he's he's got issues he's got issues no
question about it but
but you know it's anyway um
so
uh but then i read the hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy douglas adams uh
which is like quite really quite a good
book in philosophy i think and i was
like okay
we don't really know what the answer is
obviously
uh so but the universe the universe is
the answer and really what are the
questions we should be asking to better
understand the nature of the universe
and so then to the degree that we expand
the scope and scale of consciousness
then we'll better be able to answer the
ask the questions
um and
understand the
why we're here or what what it's all
about and so
sort of take the set of actions that are
most likely to result in us
understanding
what questions to ask about the nature
of the universe this is uh oh it's all
upside down you know i thought maybe we
had a 10 chance of reaching orbit
starting out so
then
uh
if people thought
when we started spacex they said oh
you're gonna fail
uh so i agree i think we probably will
fail
yeah it's worth trying anyway
yeah
yeah how's that for honesty huh yeah
that's this
i said i'd lose like
you know lose all the money from paypal
i was like well you're probably right
you know and we're almost there we first
three launches the falcon didn't work
and the fourth one we scraped together
some parts and then that one worked and
if that one hadn't worked it would have
been that would have been it for us so
um
i really believe in the future of space
and and i think it's important that we
become a space frank civilization
and and not be out there among the stars
and i think that's one of the things
that
you know makes people excited about the
future and
we want the things that are in science
fiction
novels and movies not to be science
fiction forever we want them to be real
one day i came to conclusion that um my
initial premise was was wrong
uh that in fact
the um
there's there's a great deal of will uh
you know that there's there's not such a
shortage um but people don't think
there's a way
um and and that if people thought there
was there was a way or do something that
wouldn't
break the federal budget um
then then people would support it
which in retrospect i think is actually
kind of obvious because
um
the the united states is a distillation
of the human spirit of exploration um
people came here from other places
um i mean it's
you know there's no nation there's no i
mean there's no nation that that's more
a nation of explorers than united united
states but but people need to believe
that it's possible and it's that it's
not you know it's they're not going to
give up like healthcare or something
important
it's it's got to be
that that that's important so
so i thought okay well
then it's not a question of well it's
it's a question of showing that there's
a way in the beginning nobody wanted a
tesla i can tell you that
uh
the the the when we made the original
sort of roads to sports car
uh if you were like why would i want an
electric car that's
my gasoline
car works fine
i'm like no electric car is better i
should try it
and it was you know hard to get people
to
do a test drive
first one nobody knew who we were never
heard of this company
and like yeah we're named after nikola
tesla you know that guy nope
um
so
for sure we were doing push in the
beginning because people said there was
no one telling us that they wanted an
electric car so it was not it was not
out of like
you know it was like lots of people
coming up to me saying hey i really want
an electric car
i heard that zero times um
somebody like it's like man we're gonna
make an electric car and show that these
things can be good
um and then people want them
um
you know it's like i think it's like
henry ford said that like the you know
we're talking about the model t it's
like if you ask the public what they
wanted they'd say a faster horse
so if you did like a big survey and say
well hey public before
aunt
what would you like it's like well i'd
like my horse to go three miles an hour
faster and eat less food and
uh
you know be stronger and
live longer and that kind of thing
there will be basically a bunch of
incremental improvements on horse
um
because people
when you say like well what about an
automobile that car that drives itself
like what are you talking about that's
not that sounds crazy um
but when you actually make an automobile
and give it to people and say okay
now this is a horse where you can keep
it in the barn and if you leave for a
month it's still alive
[Laughter]
yeah
to carry more more weight than a horse
and go further and that kind of thing so
yeah the
it's like when when it's a radically new
product people don't know that they want
it because it's just not in their
in their scope i think when they first
started making tvs
they did a nationwide survey
i think this might have been like
46 or 48 it's like famous nationwide
survey will you ever buy a tv
now it was like 96 percent of
respondents said no
some crazy number
like basically everyone's like would you
buy a tv and maybe they put a price in
there or something i don't know but
it was famously
almost everyone said they would not buy
tv but they didn't know what they're
talking about
so the big game changing stuff at the
beginning is a company push kind of a
thing most of the time but then changes
to the product over time can be a lot
more customer pull kind of a focus
yeah changes the product over time can
be
incremental changes
um
then the customers can certainly tell
you it's good to get customer feedback
to say how can we improve the product
and once they're using it they can say
okay i like this thing about it i don't
like this other thing and then we can
improve the product over time customer
feedback after they they have
the fundamental thing
is is great don't just follow the trend
so um
you may have heard me say
that it's good to think in terms of
the physics approach of first principles
which is
rather than reasoning by analogy you
boil things down to
the most fundamental truths you can
imagine and you reason up from there
and this is a good way to figure out if
if if something really makes sense or if
it's just what everybody else is doing
it's hard to think that way you can't
think think that way about everything it
takes a lot of effort
but if you're trying to do something new
it's the best way to think
and that framework was developed by by
physicists to figure out
counterintuitive things
um like quantum mechanics so
it's really a powerful powerful method i
believe in the scientific method and one
should be one should have a healthy
skepticism of things in general and
you know as if first things from a
scientific standpoint you always look at
things probabilistically not
definitively and so i think a lot of
times if somebody's a skeptic in the
science community what they're really
saying is that they're not sure that
it's 100 certain that that this is the
case but that's that's that's not the
point the point is um
that is is it's looking from the other
side see
what do you think the percentage chance
is of of this being
catastrophic for some meaningful
percentage of the earth's population
is it greater than one percent is it
even one percent
um if it is even one percent why are we
running this experiment you think about
a company a company is is a group of
people that are organized to create a
product or service
that's what a company is so in order to
create such a thing you have to convince
others to join you in in your effort
and
and and so they have to be convinced
that that that it's a sensible thing
that uh it's like that there's at least
some some good some reasonable chance of
success uh and if if there is success
that
the reward will be commensurate with the
effort involved
and
you know so i think that's
getting people to to
believe in what you're doing uh and in
in you is is important um
so in in the beginning
there will be there will be a few people
who
who who believe in you or in what you're
doing
and
but then over time as you make progress
the the evidence will build and
and more people will believe in what
you're doing so
um i think it's a good idea when
creating a company to
um
to create it to have a demonstration or
you know if it's a product to have like
a
a good mock-up or even if software to
have good demo wear
or to be able to sketch something so
people can really envision what it's
about
like that that's a try to get to that
point as soon as possible and then
iterate to make it as as real as
possible as fast as possible if you're
going to try something innovative then
then you're in unexplored territories so
that odds that something will go wrong
are pretty high
if you know it's only if you try to do
something that is already well
understood that um there's
a little little chance of failure
but then it will not be uh interesting
or innovative um
so
you know for sure uncharted territory
will result in
failures
necessarily otherwise you know trying
hard enough did you surround yourself
with mentors how did you who did you
look to for advice
i read a lot of books and talked to lots
of people um i didn't have any any one
person who was a mentor but i always
look for feedback from from people
around me and
feedback from uh in historical context
to you know which is books basically i
certainly was
quite um i was very very bookish i was
reading all the time so i was either
reading
uh working on my computer
reading comics playing dungeon dragons
that kind of thing
i understand hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy that wonderful book by douglas
adams that was a that was a key book for
you
what was it about that book that that
fired your imagination um yeah so
uh i guess when i was
in the around 12 or 13 i had a company
existential crisis and i was reading
various books
um
on
trying to figure out the meaning of life
and well like what does it all mean
because
uh it
it starts seeming quite meaningless and
then
uh my we happen to have like some some
books by nietzsche and schopenhauer in
the house which you should not read at
age 14
is bad
it's really negative
um
so so uh but but then i then i read the
hitchhiker's guide the galaxy was like
quite positive i think and
um
and it sort of highlighted the the an
important point which is that a lot of
times the question is harder than the
answer and if you can properly phrase
the question then the answer is the easy
part
and so
uh
the if to agree that we can
better
uh understand the universe then we
better know what questions to ask and um
then whatever the question is that most
approx approximates what's the meaning
of life
you know that that's that's the question
we could ultimately get closer to
understanding
um
and so i thought well to agree that we
can expand the scope and scale of
consciousness and
give knowledge
um
human knowledge then that would be a
good thing
when we interview people we we do ask
for some evidence of exceptional ability
which in most cases
includes innovation
this is not said everyone needs to be
innovative it's
but we certainly need those that are
doing advanced engineering to be
innovative
and ideally everyone is at least some to
some degree innovative
uh so at the
interview point
we
select for it for people who want to
create new technology
and then the incentive structure
is
set up that such that
uh
innovation is rewarded
um making mistakes
along the way does not come with a big
penalty
um
and but but failure to try to innovate
at all comes with a big penalty
you'll be fired okay
yeah all right the carrot and stick yes
the stick if you don't even try um or or
somebody doesn't even try to innovate or
their innovation um aspirations are are
very are
not not very good
then
yeah they will no longer be at the
company i don't have a mentor per se
although i try to
i try to get feedback from as many
people as possible
um
and um
so i have like friends and i ask them to
you know what they think of this that
that the other thing and um
you know
as much you know larry's a good lady
page is a good friend of mine value his
advice a lot um
and um and many other good friends and
uh so so i think it's good to solicit
feedback uh and particularly negative
feedback actually because you know
obviously people aren't don't love the
idea of giving you negative feedback um
unless unless it's like some
you know on on blogs they they do that
we're gonna look at some memes right yes
and say things that are say funny things
about them i think we rate them oh we
rate them okay that's the review and
then we're reviewing them out of ten of
course okay i mean there's some good
memes here is this the first one i
believe so okay yeah a spoon is just a
small bowl on a stick used to eat from a
larger bowl he's earnestly presenting
this in congress and you can see
you can see how how how easy it would be
to just replace that text and add
anything you want there
it's almost as though he wasn't saying
that so yeah i rate this uh
out of what's the scale one to ten yeah
is it one to ten
oh uh i have five i guess yeah six maybe
maybe a six yeah is this it's like a
mid-range it's a mid-range meme yeah i
don't think this one's got legs also
it's kind of tipping into the political
area which is like yeah who needs it you
know if i
like get off my lawn
[Laughter]
but just
get off my lawn
would be great that would be really good
get off my lawn
okay yeah okay i'll i'll bump it up
another number because that's a good so
i give it a six year of my loan man a
gas car and gas car
oh i see so you love you love madagascar
because it's just such a heartwarming
wonderful film but then gas car you're
like what i've actually never seen this
movie you've never seen no
no it's a lot of lemurs i refuse to
watch any movie with the word gas car in
it
that's not bad
but no but i think i'll make you
everything is sick
how do you
but but how do you feel about it is that
trippy to like for real there's a meme
of with you in it are you sort of like
what the hell
yeah or have you gotten over that and
you're just like yeah yeah well i mean
this past couple years have been
particularly last year it was meme city
meme city yeah meme city yeah that'd be
a lot of memes okay now this is this is
a a proper quandary
okay
okay would you step on stuart little for
18 billion dollars
i love how poorly photoshopped
it's like it's like it's like they just
they got a gray color and just erased
whatever the hell it's like and they
just put him in yeah you kid the only
sentient mouse or is it sentient or
sentient sentient sentient is it
sentient
i've always said sentient i've said
sentience
sentient sentient or sentient
stop sending me this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's not that's not post at all who is
that guy that's me oh my god is that a
weird combination of you
and this is a real this is a is this a
real tweet no okay okay okay okay okay
man dude nothing you can't believe it
yeah yeah
this is where i'm face smashed with uh
folks alone that's a funny meme that's a
funny one you could apply it not only to
you but to other celebrities and people
so yeah i think that's a funny meme as
you look back on your career in the
space industry what has been the most
surprising or unexpected challenge that
you faced and along those lines if you
were to go back in time and talk to your
20 year old self would you do anything
differently
go back in time
to your 20 year old self
i mean i think
if i could i think it would make my far
fewer mistakes obviously if i could go
like here's a list of all the things
you're about to do please do not do them
wouldn't we all be a very long list and
like
here let me
write it down or something you know
um
i mean it's hindsight's 20 20. so it's
hard to say
um
i mean a number of i've made so many
foolish mistakes i had a lot count
honestly
um
i mean some of these things i just wish
i'd like that like that's
simple sort of mantra
management by rhyming i mean it worked
for homer
okay
the management bar rhyming is
the thing i'm saying like if but if the
schedule is long the design is wrong
we've overcomplicated the design many
times
um
and i think we should have just gone
with a simpler design
um
with the acid test being
how long will it take to
for this to fly
and if it's gonna take a long time don't
do it do something else i think we we
need to push for
radical breakthroughs um
and if you don't push radical
breakthroughs you're not going to get
radical outcomes
um
and that that does mean taking risks
um
and and yeah
common sense that
the if you take a big risk in order to
have a big reward there must be a big
risk it's
most the time
you cannot find
a big reward for small risk that's those
are rare
so you're gonna have some
proportionality the risk can reward
simplify your product as much as
possible
you know and then like if i think of
some of the ways which how does a smart
engineer make dumb mistakes
including you know
is optimize something that shouldn't
exist
don't optimize something that shouldn't
exist
um but people are trained to do this in
college you can't say no to the
professor you know professor is going to
give you the exam and you've got to
answer all the questions
or they will get angry
so
they give you a bad grade so then you
you always
optimize the you always answer the
question
a lot of the times you should say this
is the wrong question
right in fact the question is definitely
wrong to some degree just how wrong
and i think just generally taking the
approach that
your design is
some degree wrong probably a lot more
than you think
your goal is to make it less wrong over
time i had a lot of friends might try to
talk me out of
starting a rocket company because they
thought it was crazy and what friend of
mine made me watch a video of rockets
blowing up
[Laughter]
and you know there were just lots of
people thought it was a really crazy
idea and there was some people that
tried to start rocket companies not
succeeded and that they tried to talk me
out of it and um but the thing is that
but the premise for talking out of it
was well we think you're going to lose
the money that you invest i was like
well um that was my expectation anyway
so i don't really mind if i lose
you know i mean that might but i mean
it's not
it's not like i was trying to figure out
the rancor best way to invest money
right on that basis
um
you know chose space right i felt like
that's
you know i thought wow you weren't
looking at like money money market bonds
aaa bonds rocket company you weren't
like do real estate yeah
you know uh
invest in shoemaking anything um
and whoa chase is the highest roi yeah
that's that is not what i there's no no
it wasn't the premise
just thought that it was important that
humanity expand beyond earth and
we weren't doing that so maybe there was
something i could do to kind of spur
spur that on well i was just saying that
you know you want to take a moment to
appreciate things in life and the
sensations um
food's incredible uh
and like there's just so many good
things that you can experience
some of them cost nothing really
um you know
have a walk in nature or
just a nice meal and it's like wow
that's pretty great you know and
we should take a moment to appreciate
these these
little things the big things
um
the things that move your heart i think
that's probably the meaning of life as
close definitions as i can think the
real way i think you you actually
achieve intellectual property protection
is by innovating fast enough if your
rate of innovation is high
then you don't need to worry about
protecting vip
because
other companies will be copying
something that you did years ago
and that's fine you know
just make sure your rate of innovation
is fast
speed is really speed of innovation is
what is what matters
and i do i do say this to my teams like
quite a lot that innovation per unit
time as i go innovation per year if you
want to say like is is what matters not
innovation
absent time because if you wanted to
make say
um 100 improvement in something
and that took 100 years or one year
that's
radically different
so
it's like what is your rate of
innovation
that that matters and is the rate of
innovation
is that accelerating or decelerating
and a weird thing happens when companies
get big is that most companies
or organizations the bigger they get
they tend to
get less innovative
not just less innovative on a per person
basis but less innovative in the
absolute
um
and i think this is probably because the
incentive structure is not
uh
is not
there for innovation
it's not enough to use words to
encourage innovation the incentive
structure must be aligned with that
that's fundamental uh you need to work
if depending on how well you want to do
and particularly if you're starting a
company you need to work super hard
so what what does super hard mean um
well when my brother and i were starting
our first company
instead of getting an apartment we just
rented a small office and we slept on
the couch
and we showered at the the ymca
and uh we're so hot up we had just one
computer so the
the the website was up during the day
and i was coding at night
seven days a week all the time
and i i
sort of briefly had a girlfriend in that
period and in order to
be with me she had to sleep in the
office
so
i
work hard like
it i mean every waking hour that's
that's the the thing i would i would say
if if you particularly if you're
starting a company
um
and i mean if you do simple math say
like okay if somebody else is working 50
hours and you're working 100
you'll get twice as done as much done in
the course of a year as
the other company how much of your
success do you attribute to having
really audacious goals or
versus
um just not being focused on
the short-term
you know money coming in or
investors unfortunately i i
wonders have to be focused on
the short-term and money coming in when
creating a company because otherwise the
company will die
so the
i think that a lot of times people think
like creating companies
gonna be fun i would say it's not it's
really not that fun i mean there are
periods of fun and there are periods of
where it's where it's just awful um
and particularly if you're the ceo of
the company
um
you actually have a distillation of all
the worst problems in the company
um
there's no point in spending your time
on things that are going right so you
only spend on things on your time on
things that are going wrong and there
are things that are going wrong that
other people can't can't take care of so
you have like the worst you have a
filter for the crappest problem in the
company
the most pernicious and painful problem
um
so i wouldn't say it's it's i think you
have to feel quite compelled to do it
um
and have a fairly high pain threshold
and there's a friend of mine
who who says like starting companies
like
staring into your bus and and eating
glass
and there's some truth to that
um
the staring into the best part is that
you're going to be constantly facing the
the
extermination of the company
because most startups fail
it's like 90
ugly 99 of startups fail
so
uh so you that that's the staring into
the abyss part you're constantly saying
okay
if if if i don't get this right the
company will die
um
it should be quite straightforward quite
stressful
and and then
um
the eating glass part is
you've got you've got to do
you've got to do the problems you're
going to you're going to work on the
problems that the company needs you to
work on not the problems you want to
work on and
so that
that's you end up working on problems
that that
you'd really wish you weren't working on
and so that's the eating glass part
um
and that goes on for a long time if you
think you're like what is education like
you're basically downloading data and
algorithms into your brain
and
it's it's it's actually
amazingly bad in conventional education
because like it shouldn't be like this
huge chore um
so you're making it way way better um
but i mean i think i think i think a lot
of the things that i would say you've
probably heard a hundred times um
and an effect are if not
doing like the more you can gamify the
uh the process of learning the better
like
for my kids i do not have to encourage
them to play video games yeah okay i
have to like pry them from their hands
like like crack yes yes like drop that
crack needle yeah yeah
you have that problem at your house too
yeah the crack isn't addictive
yeah um
so it's
you know it's it's it's to agree that
you can make uh somehow learning like a
game but that then it's better um
and i think unfortunately like a lot of
education is very bored billion um
you've got
uh you know someone's standing up there
kind of lecturing at people
and they've done the same lecture 20
years in a row and they're not very
excited about it and that lack of
enthusiasm you know is conveyed to the
students that they're not very excited
about it they don't know why they're
there like why are we learning this
stuff we don't even know why um in fact
i think a lot of things people learn
probably there's no point in learning
them um
because they never use them in the
future because who's going to launch a
rocket into space i mean that's just
like yeah exactly that never happens
um well you have to say like people i
think don't stand back and say well why
are we teaching people these things and
we should tell them probably why we're
teaching these things because a lot of
kids just in school kind of puzzled as
to why they're there
and i think if you can explain the why
of things
then that makes a huge difference to
people's motivation yeah then they
understand
they understand purpose and think about
the various problems that we're facing
or what would most likely change the
future um
the when they were in college there were
five things that i thought would be
um i mean i thought these were actually
these these i would not regard this as a
profound insight but rather an obvious
one
uh
the
the internet would fundamentally change
humanity because it's it's like
humanity will become more of a super
organism because the internet is like
the nerve like nervous system um now
suddenly any part of the human
human organisms
anywhere would have access to all the
information amazing instantly zero link
hey well i can imagine if you didn't
have a nervous system
you wouldn't know what's going on your
fingers wouldn't know what's going on
your toes would know what's going on
you'd have to do it by diffusion
um
and yeah and the way information used to
work was really by diffusion one human
would have to call another human or or
or write them yes like if it was a
letter
you would have to write like you'd have
to have that letter to another human
that would be carried through a bunch of
things fine another person would give it
to you
extremely slow diffusion
um and if you wanted access to books if
you were not did not have a library
you're not you don't have it that's it
so
um now you have access to all the books
instantly
um
and
you you if you can be in a remote like
you know mountaintop jungle location or
something and have access to
all of humanity's information if you've
got a link to the internet
this was a fundamental profound change
let me just tell the story that you can
correct the story
i mean yeah let's see if the story that
you tell is actually how does that how
that compares to the reality because the
reality is pretty messed up so hopefully
the reality is better so you wreck the
car you get out of the car you're
doubling over with laughter
and the person with you said
why are you laughing that you just
wrecked this car and you said no you
don't know the funny part it wasn't
insured
well
the punchline's correct
[Laughter]
yeah so i was actually i was driving up
sandhill road
um with with peter thiel the co-founders
of paypal we're actually driving to see
mike moritz
um this is in in uh 2000.
and uh so we're driving up to san jose i
didn't really know how to drive the
mclaren and uh peter says so
so what can this do
and then like
i'm probably number one on the list of
famous last words i said watch this
[Laughter]
so i so i floored it i floored it and
did a lane change um on on san diego and
so the mclaren has no uh
attraction control or anything it's just
it's massive power to to the wheels so
640 brake horsepower and it only weighs
a ton
so it has massive power weight it can
break the wheels free at 80 miles an
hour
so broke the the rear end free
and and started spinning
um and uh i i i sort of let's see i
think it was sort of i was going
straight and then turned
um
and and i remember seeing the the the
cars coming towards me while i was going
backwards and then we hit the hit an
embankment um sort of a 45 degree
embankment on sand hill which tossed the
car into the air like a discus and it
kept broke it kept rotating with about
three foot of air clearance according to
witnesses
um
and and then slammed down on on on the
ground going the original direction
and we blew the suspension out uh and uh
now it didn't actually wreck the car the
core chassis and the engine were okay
um
but all the glass and the wheels and
everything was shredded and um and there
was massive body damage in the front and
rear um
and
yeah
did you start laughing
um i don't recall laughing um i i mean
i
i could have been laughing in shock
but i don't recall laughing um
and um and then and then peter uh caught
a hitched a ride to to mike i i waited
while the the fire truck and the
ambulance arrived then finally the did
peter thiel literally hitch a ride to to
like to yeah over to to sequoia to yeah
and then then i once once the car was uh
taken care of then i i used to ride too
um and so we continued the meeting
that's i'm picturing you and peter thiel
like that scene and tommy boy we're like
the deer and you're both like oh
like yeah really
how wow yeah is there apparel
really
i should say so is there a parallel with
how you build companies in that story i
hope not
let's see what this thing can do
yeah watch this
that could be awkward with a rocket
launch if you want another video on how
billionaires think check it out right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there we don't love this product but we
think others will love it you know
that's not really how it works if you
don't love it don't expect others will
either your relationship with time is
such a key component
of your life because